[Music]  hello mark so what you've been up to for  20 years choose life choose Facebook  Twitter Instagram and hope that someone  somewhere cares miss you much I missed  you too Sparky  cheers looking up old flames wishing  you'd done all differently do you still  take heroin no and she's watching  history repeats itself  Oh Simon  choose your future call the police what  shall I say just tell them we're dead  choose reality TV slut-shaming revenge  porn choose a zero hour contracts a  two-hour journey to work and choose the  same for your kids only worse and  smother the pain with an unknown dose of  an unknown drug made in somebody's  kitchen and then take a deep breath  you're an addict so be addicted just be  addicted to something else  choose the ones you love  choose your future  choose light